there's nothing worse that's right the
lows are the lowest in the world how
could they you're literally getting your
ass beat it's gotta be awful but i feel
like this one's bigger than that because
this one's like a life questioning yes
you know what i mean it's like because
you already i you you 125 new energy new
lease on life just gonna come in and rip
this thing took off the 135
now you're going home do i even want to
do this correct vibe
he's inspirational even when he just
says yeah you know i get it dude
you know and somehow i'm not the one
sucking his dick even still you are yes
right right so how did that happen
you're a life coach right is that what
you do yeah so give me confidence i'm
gonna give you a problem i suck at
business
sell merch you're inside
that's not four you're inside four walls
you're inside four walls you're inside
four walls
okay tell me more this is so [ __ ]
you're looking down you're looking up
but guess what's in the middle what it's
a window where
it's exactly your problem where where
where yeah you're looking around it's in
front of you oh it's here okay lift it
up open the window
and your heart will open too
i feel like i can do anything wrong
no you need to get the likeness no it's
not a goal i don't know how you don't
know what i do no all right it's your
design